[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Rachel's
in Independence Kansas hi Rachel how are
you good how are you better than I
deserve what's
up hello I was wanting um a little bit
of advice if you could about um I um my
Exon and I broke up about a few months
ago and we have over the course of the
last five years wrapped up some debts
and that's what we have um both of our
names in and I've been advised um but um
by family members like oh the only way
for me to start fresh and um maybe get
get our names off of each other's stuff
is they go bankrupt and I just kind of
wanted a an outside um perspective or
outside um piece of advice rather than
just going off of like the lawyers
perspective
yeah asking a bankruptcy law you're if
you're bankrupt like asking a dog if
it's
hungry
yeah yeah how old are you
Rachel I am 29 okay how long y'all been
broke
up um it's been about two
months after five years
huh yeah oh okay
um so how many different items are you
attached to each other
on I it looks like only about
fiveish fiveish okay what are the
fiveish
items um a house two
cars and then at least two if not three
loans I'm trying to find out if there's
another one that's in both of our names
are just
mine okay all right
no credit
cards um I have credit cards but I don't
believe both of our names are on the
credit cards okay any checking
accounts yes I have with both names oh
no we didn't do that oh no of course
not okay uh but both your names are on
the cars and on the loans on the house
deed and on the
loan yes okay what's the house
worth um that's a good question um the
lawyer asked or says you should look on
Zillow um I thought that there wasn't
going to be any equity in the house um
but from what Zillow says it's worth 130
and we have 90 on it but we just
refinance I don't know how accurate that
is okay and you signed all of that okay
signed all it yeah and what do you make
um I just got a new job um so I was
making about about 60 is 65 a year now
with a new job I will be making like
around 80 85 okay all right and what do
you owe on the
cars each car which what each car and
what are they
worth um see the one is worth 40 well we
got the loan for 42,000 I think we owe
about 30 something left on the truck and
then another
car it's around 20,000 and I believe we
still owe around that okay and which one
are you
driving um the car okay all right
um okay and uh I'm assuming you have
discussed this with him after the
breakup what's that sound what's that
sounding like
yeah we um seem to We divied Up expenses
um he got since he and the boys um I
want you know I didn't want them to move
out of the house I decided to move out
sorry the
boys he has um boys from a previous
marriage oh his
sons yeah okay all right and they're in
the
house yeah okay all right well uh what I
would tell you to do
um if you were my daughter um is to go
uh hopefully with
someone uh in your family just to sit
there for moral support and not say
anything sit down and meet with him in
person and say um this is an ugly mess
and neither one of our Lives go forward
easily with this mess unless we together
figure out some way to undo the mess
here's my proposal to undo the mess okay
uh you refinance the house and get the
mortgage off of my name and I will deed
it to
you you get the truck out out of my name
either by selling it or by refinancing
it I will do the same with the car that
I'm driving I will either sell it or I
will refinance it and get your name off
of it that will leave only $8,000 that
the two of us have to pay off together
and I'm going to aggressively pay that
off um probably uh in the next few
months okay because if you don't do that
it's all going to land in his lap and
you will have filed bankruptcy for no
reason because you're not bankrupt you
just have a partnership
disillusionment another route you can go
technically speaking but it's not very
practical is if he refuses to do what I
just asked him to do
um you can sue him for the
disillusionment of a partnership what
you have technically and you'd have to
asking a different attorney not a
bankruptcy attorney about this is my
opinion is you have a general
partnership without any partnership
documents or agreements the two of you
as two individuals that were not married
went and bought a bunch of crap
together and um now that partnership has
to be undone and you're asking the court
to force him to do what I just asked him
to do that'll cost you about
$10,000 probably if you're lucky I
wouldn't do with that I would I might
sue him just to get him to make him do
it and then the suit gets dropped
hopefully you don't to take it all the
way to court though um
but uh filing bankruptcy on this uh you
know it's kind of like taking poison and
hoping he
dies you're killing you when you file
bankruptcy
and he gets all the debt he's going to
be left with the car the
truck and the house and the $8,000 debt
that's what he's going to be left
with all of that gets dumped on him when
you're no longer on it because of
bankruptcy but you're and you're free
but you now have filed
bankruptcy um which is like dropping an
atom bomb on a pissant in this situation
it's a little bit
Overkill a lot Overkill is what I'm
trying to say so I I think the two of
you ought to try to sit down and work
this out like two mature adults I have a
feeling that's probably not possible
though what do you
think we have sat down and talked um so
both of our just over the last few years
our credit has tanked really bad so we
have talked about doing this in the
future so how about selling all three of
these things then sell the house the
truck and the
car everything gets sold
well I mean we they wouldn't have a
place to live and oh darling there's all
kinds of rental properties right there
around Independence freaking
Kansas and you get you a hoopie and
you're not bankrupt and you got out of
this mess yeah folks ladies and
gentlemen when I tell you people
shacking up not to do
this Rachel is a case study on why not
to do this don't buy a house for people
you're not married to don't act like
you're married to people you're not
married to don't set up life with people
you're not married to you get screwed in
the process metaphorically this is the
Ramsey Show